- It's interesting 'cause we see
that also with the...
Like the plants and
herbs and spices
that I mentioned,
with their built-in
plant defense mechanisms,
or some of these centenarians
who are smoking like
a cigarette a day,
or the exposure to the
radiation from sunlight,
or the stress of heat or cold,
like I was talking about,
it's kind of like this concept
of what's called hormesis,
things that would be bad for you
in large amounts,
like alcohol, which is
technically a toxin,
are actually good for you
in small amounts
because like exercise,
they beat up the body,
but the body in the process
of bouncing back
becomes stronger,
it builds more antioxidants,
the cells become stronger,
and so it's not an idea
of living super clean.
By living super clean,
you can actually become
a little bit more weak,
it's about exposing your
body to these mild stressors.
(gentle music)
- I'm Dave Rubin
and joining me today is a
human performance consultant,
a speaker,
and a "New York Times"
best selling author of 17,
yeah, 17 books,
including "Beyond
Training," "Boundless,"
and "Fit Soul."
Ben Greenfield, welcome
to "The Rubin Report."
- Hey, what's going on, man?
- Ben, this is a
first time for me,
I have never had a guest,
I've probably interviewed about
a 1000 people at this point,
I don't think I've
ever had a guest
just sorta wandering
in the forest.
First time.
- Really?
Have you ever had a guest
wandering in the forest naked?
- Are you bare ass naked?
- Well, in this area,
you never know when
someone is wearing pants,
but considering that I'm
walking through the neighborhood
and not strolling in the
treadmill in my office,
I did have to pull on a
little bit of clothing,
but I'll try not to have
any wardrobe malfunctions
during our show here.
- Fair enough.
- I just like to...
Like to get my
vitamin D, you know?
- Yeah, yeah, this is
YouTube, not Pornhub,
let's keep it clean.
All right, so as you know,
right now, I am off
the grid completely,
we are taping this
at the end of July
for an August release,
I am completely away
from cell phones,
all tech, television, news,
the whole thing,
I'm working on diet,
I'm working on exercise,
and I'm working on
a digital detox.
Let's start there with the
digital detox situation,
as a guy
that's doing YouTube interviews
while doing exercise
and wandering around,
I take it you think maybe
we're a little too
connected these days?
- Well, first of all,
I don't know how the
heck you're staying fit
during a digital detox
without being able
to be motivated
by all the Instagram
influencers out there
because we all know the best way
to get fit is via osmosis
and scrolling through babe
and hulk feeds on Instagram.
But that being said,
yeah, I...
Honestly like...
I really took a great
deal of pride for years
in being like one of those
hyper-connected guys,
and by hyper-connected,
I don't mean on
social media all day,
but I mean using
all the wearables,
the self quantification devices,
the super computers on my bike,
the power meters on
my laces for running,
the swimming goggles
that tell you how
many laps you swam...
With like a screen right there
in the goggle.
- Yeah.
- And...
I really like to be a little
bit more unplugged now,
I'm pretty bare bones
when it comes to fitness,
I wear like a ring
that tracks my step
count in my sleep
and a cheap ass $15
Timex, you know?
And that's about
all that I do now,
but I think even more
related to your point
is this idea
that the more connected you are,
the more difficult
it can be to move
and to exercise because...
It's just difficult to engage
on something like social media
while you're working
out, you know?
Which is obviously
why half the people
at a gym have their
assess parked on a bench,
hunched over looking on
their phones rather than...
But before that it was all...
It was magazines
and the TV,
now, it's just been
replaced by phones.
But I think
that there can be some
efficacy to that stuff,
like I'd even seen during COVID,
I mean, some of these companies,
'cause I do some
investing in the health
and fitness sector as well,
and I've seen the valuation
of some of these like
home fitness companies,
the Pelotonese
companies like Tonal
and Mirror and Katalyst
and Fight club...
And then of course,
Peloton as well, just explode,
and obviously, you
need to be connected
to use those type of
products during your session,
some of them allow for
like offline downloading
of the workouts,
which I actually encourage
people to do if they can
'cause it's one
less distraction,
one less notification going off
on your device while you're
working out, et cetera.
And possibly, even
a bigger thing here
that a lot of people
don't think about
is all of these devices,
all these things you
need to be connected to,
they do emit low-level radiation
that could be problematic
in terms of your
mitochondrial function,
your red blood cell,
what's called red
blood cell stickiness
or the propensity
of red blood cells
to aggregate together the
calcium influx into a cell
which cause a little
bit more of a burn
and a slower ability to be
able to buffer lactic acid
and some of the things
that build up during
the lactic aci...
Or during exercise,
a lot of that stuff actually
becomes effected by exposure
to your cell phone signal,
5G, wi-fi, et cetera,
that's why a lot of people
during a day of work,
they get brain fog,
they feel kinda blah
in the afternoon,
they don't sleep well,
they got a bunch of
devices next to their bed,
and so I question the impact
some of those things
are having on you while
you're exercising as well,
if you are using those types
of things during the exercise,
then of course
the use apart from
exercise is just...
It can be a time suck,
but there's some efficacy,
I'm not...
I see a ton of benefit
in social media
for spreading a lot of good
knowledge and information,
obviously, it can
spread disinformation,
negativity as well,
but I think when
responsibly used,
it's a big blessing.
- Yeah, you mentioned
Tonal and Mirror,
and I just was at the
mall the other day,
I saw a Tonal,
so it's basically like
these mirror type...
I mean, they're
literally mirrors
that you stand in
front of to work out,
they have some things
you can pull on,
and yeah, they're
connected to the internet
and all that,
do you think there's a risk
in people actually doing
this stuff all from home
and not going to the gym,
not being around other people,
getting that kind of motivation?
- Well, first, not really,
because they enable people
to be able to actually...
Yeah, just lower the
barrier of entry, right?
If you can roll out of bed
and walk over to your...
Whatever, your basement
or your backyard or whatever,
and just use a home
training device,
and furthermore relate
to the safety component,
use a home training device
that now has the ability
to have a personal trainer
or an expert walking
you through the workout,
and again, sometimes like...
I do like full body electrical
muscle stimulation workouts,
which sounds crazy,
but I mean,
it's very simply,
just pull on this suit
and it stimulates your muscles
while you're exercising
so you use more muscles.
And it has a personal trainer
that walks you
through the workout,
but I can download
all those workouts
'cause they're prerecorded.
And it's actually very,
very similar to what
you might experience
in a group fitness
class at a health club
or a gym,
so I'm not really against that,
I mean, I think that
probably the two main things
that we miss out on
by not being able
to go to a health club or gym
or by kind of like making
those highly optional
due to the emergence
of a lot of these
higher end home fitness
training devices is that,
A, we know that human beings
thrive on connectivity
to other human beings,
touch, our eyes,
even the electromagnetic
signals sent out by our hearts
and our brains,
we are designed to be social
creatures just based on
that whole idea that...
In more ancestral times,
to be banished
or cut off from the village
or from your tribe
usually resulted in death,
and we still have kind of
that nervous system
and physiological
response to isolation
that causes a lot
of the health issues
that we're now seeing,
we saw it before COVID,
we see it more now,
just this idea
that human beings
don't thrive when
we are alone for
long periods of time,
and digital interactions
do not replace the...
What happens physiologically
during physical interactions.
And then the...
In addition to
missing out on that,
and that can be replaced
by dinner partings
and outings and hanging out
with friends, et cetera,
but the other thing is that
there's a lot of value as well
to shared experiences, right?
And honestly, that's even
more important for men
than for women.
Men tend to bond over
shared experiences,
shared workouts, shared...
Noon basketball
games at the gym,
shared tennis matches,
like that's how guys a lot
of times form friendships,
that's one thing I found is...
When I wanna make friends,
I'll invite them
out for Frisbee golf
or over to my house
to do a garage workout
or something like that,
and if you're always
working out by yourself
in front of some mirror mirror
on the wall at your house,
you're also missing out on that.
So I would say if you're aware
of the importance of
real human interaction
and shared experiences,
and you're fabricating those
somewhere else in your life,
then working out
by yourself at home
with some of these home
fitness training devices,
especially because of...
Like I mentioned,
the low barrier to entry
that occurs when you don't
have to get in the car,
or drive to the gym,
figure out what
time the class is,
show up, shower, go home.
For me personally,
if I have a chance to
work out during the day,
it's like a 20
or 30 minute slot a couple
of times during the day,
and I could use all
that time driving to the gym,
or I could just hop
out to my garage
or my backyard
or my basement,
throw something down,
and that's what I do
like 90% of the time,
and I get all my
social interaction
through group dinners
and church outings
and playing tennis with folks
and stuff like that,
so...
See I still think the
pros outweigh the cons
of a lot of these trendy
fitness devices for home.
- Right, so since I'm in the
middle of nowhere right now,
disappeared throughout August,
my goal basically is...
In terms of working out, eating,
that sort of thing,
is I'd love to lose a
couple pounds off the belly,
I'd tightened up a little bit,
and just eat right
and feel good
and obviously, the digital detox
is the mental portion of that,
what do you tell people
that are just trying
to just be like
a little bit better
than they are,
not do like full
transformations?
- Well, let's not bore
people with the idea
that you should exercise
and eat healthy, right?
Let's assume that
you've already learned
that you're supposed to
engage in physical activity
on a regular basis
and you're supposed
to eat a diet
that's high in healthy
recognizable foods,
preferably somewhat low in sugar
and vegetable oils, right?
Like that's just the basics.
- So far, so good, I'm there.
- Well, yeah, yeah, exactly.
But then a lot of people,
like, "I'm not seeing results,"
"I still have low
energy levels,"
"I still have poor sleep,"
"My gut isn't working the way
that I want it to,"
"When I try to work out,
I feel kind of blah,"
"I get these food cravings
that dictate that
I can't stick to
that healthy whole diet
that you talk about."
Well, then there's the things
that like "Men's
Health" magazine
and "Women's Health..."
All these...
Modern forms of fitness
media don't tell you,
and really, it all comes
down to viewing your body
as a battery.
I mean, the human
body actually operates
on a finely tuned
electro-chemical gradient
across the membrane
of every cell,
and if you can take that concept
and incorporate modalities
into your routine
that take advantage of the fact
that you have the ability
to be able to charge
up your body's battery,
then you begin to see results
that are highly amplified
over just exercising
and eating healthy.
So what I mean by that is...
Well, I'd say there's
probably like six things
to really focus on,
one would be a light, right?
Like I'm walking out in
the sunlight right now,
we know that photons of light,
particularly from the sun,
or even from these
new fangled-like
infrared light panels
or infrared saunas
that are becoming
very popular nowadays,
these actually act to
charge up the mitochondria,
they speed up the activity
of what's called the
electron transport chain,
they help you to
produce more ATP,
they allow the heart to
function more effectively.
They can lower blood pressure,
increase the effectiveness
or the efficiency of the
cardiovascular system.
And so the regular use of
things like infrared saunas,
infrared light panels,
and regular sun exposure,
like this idea that
you should get out
in the sun every single day,
we know that skin cancer is
an issue with people who tan
or burn or visit the
beach on the weekends,
and people who like
work in the sun
or in the sun
regularly every day,
they don't have
those same issues
'cause you almost build up
almost like this sun callus.
So...
- Right.
- Regular...
- I live in LA..
and I've got an infrared sauna,
so so far I'm doing all right.
- Yeah, perfect.
Regular exposure to light,
particularly in the morning
because that's what
helps you sleep at night,
that's what basically
sends your body the message
that its circadian rhythm
has begun in the morning,
that's number one for
charging up your body.
Number two would be
another form of charge
that we have at constant access,
and it's this concept of
earthing or grounding,
like walking outside barefoot,
walking barefoot on the beach,
swimming in the ocean,
touching trees, touching rocks,
lying with your shirt
off in your backyard,
the earth actually meets
these negative ions
and low level frequencies
that are incredible for
decreasing inflammation,
for again, increasing
the charge potential
across those cell membranes,
there are books like "Earthing"
or documentaries
like "Grounding"
that kind of walk
people through this.
And kind of like
the sun is free,
but there's like
those light panels
or saunas we talked about.
Earthing and going
outside barefoot is free,
but there are also companies now
that sell like mats
that you can put
underneath your top sheet
that you sleep on
during the night
that plug into the grounding
outlet of your home.
Or like in my office,
back in my office,
I have a mat I stand
on all day long
and it's just got a little wire
and a stake planted
in the ground outside,
so it's as though I'm
constantly connected
to the surface of the planet.
Sounds kind of woo,
but a ton of people
see huge increases
in energy by not only
regular sunlight exposure,
but also regular exposure
to the surface of the planet,
so that's another
one to think about.
Heat and cold are
really popular now.
Saunas and like
cryotherapy chambers,
and cold plunges, cold soaks,
those actually do a really,
really good job
at also enhancing
that electron flow
through the body.
You also get production of
things like heat shock proteins
and cold shock proteins,
which are fantastic
for your immune system
and for cellular resilience.
You get better weight loss,
especially if you
do like the cold
and a fasted state
in the morning
because you burn a
lot of fatty acids
to generate heat,
there's just so many benefits
to this idea of regularly
doing heat and cold,
I mean, almost
every morning for me
is 20 to 30 minutes
in the sauna,
two to five minutes in the ice
or in some cold body of water.
- Mm-hmm.
- And I mean,
everybody who I put
on that protocol,
especially when they combine
it with like sunlight
and being outside barefoot,
they see huge,
huge improvements compared to,
again, just exercising
or eating healthy.
And then the last two things
to think about would be...
You have to carry these
charges through your body,
and the way that
that's done is via
water and minerals,
so regular intake
of really good,
clean, pure filtered water,
like I start every day
and then re-dose
again in the afternoon
with a giant,
32 ounce glass of water with
electrolytes added to it,
I put vitamin C in there.
- Mm-hmm.
- A little bit of baking soda,
which is alkaline
and kind of offsets the
acidity of the vitamin C,
and then minerals.
And so I drink that
down in the morning
and then again in the afternoon,
and so what I'm doing
is I'm giving my body
not only the fluid
that it needs to build blood
and carry these minerals
through the body,
but the minerals themselves.
We're often salt
phobic these days
because of the impression
we've been given
about the deleterious
effects of salt,
and it is true
that salt can cause
some damage to the body,
can increase blood
pressure, et cetera,
but what we're talking about
is isolated sodium chloride
that you'd find
in like table salt
or in...
Let's say like packaged foods
which use sodium chloride
as a preservative,
but a wide range of minerals
and electrolytes that
you would get from like
produce grown in
mineral rich soil,
or these like really,
really good salts,
like sea salts
and rock salts
and Kona black salts...
All these salts you
can add to your food
and sprinkle in your water,
I am a salt fiend,
I go through tons of salt,
I go through tons of water,
I do the sauna
and the cold every day,
I'm out in the
sunlight every day,
I get in touch with the surface
of the planet every day,
and man, oh, man,
when you combine that
with physical activity
and eating a healthy diet,
like those are the things
that people can do
that a lot of times
folks don't think about,
but that's where you really
start moving the dial.
- Right, so let's talk
about the diet stuff,
so...
'Cause I think a lot of people,
especially in the last year
and a half,
they've realized that
they gotta take control
of their health
and their lives...
Trapped at home,
you can't go to the gym,
you're eating takeout food,
everything's being delivered,
et cetera, et cetera,
what's like some
basic dietary stuff
that people should know?
- Well...
The fact is that based on
biochemical individuality,
different shapes of the stomach,
the pancreas, the liver,
different vitamin
D excretion rates
and different ways
that we all process food
as unique human beings,
paired with the fact
that we all have
unique genetics, right?
Like someone from,
let's say, Sub-Saharan Africa
is going to do far better
based on equatorial location
and sun exposure
to high carb intake
and lots of fruits
and a lower amount of
like saturated fats,
compared to someone
Northern European descent
who does really
good on like fish,
steak, fermented foods...
High fat milk,
stuff like that.
- Mm-hmm.
- The idea is that it's not
gonna be the same for everybody,
but we live in an era in which
the same type of self
quantification tests
that would have cost like
tens of thousands of dollars,
let's say like,
the Princeton
Longevity Institute,
or Duke,
or any of these places
where a lot of execs
would normally get
tested to really,
really dial in
something like diet
or nutrition or supplementation,
those are available to us
in the comfort of
our own home now
for a fraction of the cost,
so people can test their blood,
they can test their genetics,
they can test their
stool for like
what the gut is asking for,
and by testing your body,
by looking at your genetics,
and by paying attention
to your own unique
biochemical individuality,
you should be able to
tweak your diet to you,
and what I mean by that is like
the same ketogenic diet
that your neighbor
used to lose 20 pounds
might be super crappy for you
and cause inflammation
and weight gain in you
because you have a liver
and gallbladder that
isn't processing
that high intake of
saturated fats very well,
or you have,
let's say, like an APOE e4 gene,
which would dictate
that high intake of
fats predisposes you
to Alzheimer's or dementia,
or you have poor
enzyme production
that dictates that
you can't burn fats
that well because you
don't have enough lipase.
And so that's just one
example of the fact
that there is no one diet
that works well for everyone.
And that being said,
a couple of things
to think about,
first of all,
when you look at
epidemiological data for a wide,
wide variety of the
world's populations,
probably because humans
likely originated
somewhere in the
Fertile Crescent,
something along the lines
of like a low carbish
Mediterranean diet tends
to work really well
for a lot of people...
Not like an Olive Garden
unlimited breadsticks diet,
but I mean like a diet
very rich in herbs
and spices and a wide
variety of plant matter,
some amounts of fish and eggs,
red meat, but in moderation,
lots of healthy
omega-3 fatty acids,
not only from those fish,
but things like extra
virgin olive oil
and avocados and avocado oil
and seeds and nuts,
like that low carb
Mediterranean profile
tends to be something
that seems to agree
with a lot of people.
And then when you look
at these blue zones,
these longevity hotspots
around the world
like Nicoya and Ikaria
and Sardinia and Loma Linda,
even though the
diets widely vary
in terms of low
carb, high fat...
High carb, low fat,
different plants and herbs
and spices being used
in those regions,
different forms of
alcohol intake, et cetera,
what we do see in terms of
prevailing characteristics
in all those regions is,
A, there's always some
semblance of fasting worked in,
a lot of times it's based
on religious concepts...
Like the Mediterranean diet,
that's very popular among like
Eastern Orthodox Christians,
and then there's a ton of
special fasts in that diet,
certain days where you
don't eat red meat,
certain periods of time
where you're avoiding a
high intake of proteins,
certain periods of time
where you're just
straight up fasting,
we see fasting as one
predominant characteristic
of every single healthy diet
on the face of the planet,
some type of fasting
and some type of
time during the day
or the week
or the month where you're
not eating a lot of protein,
'cause protein in high amounts
can tend to have a little bit
of an accelerated aging effect.
We also see the concept of
eating with people, right?
Not only saying grace
or having a moment of silence
or having a moment
of appreciation
or sacredness around a meal,
but also not stuffing your face
with a super food smoothie
while you're going 65 miles
an hour down the highway
on your way to work,
instead, and I'm highly
kind of doing this myself,
if I'm gonna eat,
I always eat in what's called
a parasympathetic state,
I sit down,
I do a little...
Just a few centering breaths,
like in through the nose,
out through the mouth,
I say grace,
I chew each bite 25 to 40 times,
I try to eat with people
so I'm not distracted
by my computer,
by my phone,
but instead, I'm
visiting with people,
and we see that as another
predominant characteristic
of a healthy diet,
like eating in a
very low stress state
and eating with people.
And then you also see
a wide intake of a
huge variety of plants
and herbs and spices,
and I realized
that diets like the paleo diet
or the carnivore diet,
or a lot of these highly
restrictive diets have popped up
and become very
popular over the years,
and a big premise of those diets
is that they eliminate
a lot of built-in plant
defense mechanisms,
like plants can't move,
and so because they
don't have hooves
and teeth and claws,
they develop things like gluten
and lectins and other things
that would cause a mammal's gut
to be a little bit disturbed,
cause that mammal to
poop out the seeds
of that plant elsewhere
so that plant can flourish
or cause that mammal not
to come back to that plant
to eat it again cause
it kind of hurt.
And so if you have
a compromised gut,
or if you have the inability
to be able to do like our
ancestors would have done
and soak and sprout and ferment
and properly prepare a
lot of your plant matter,
then yeah, doing
something like a paleo
or a carnivore
diet has efficacy.
However, in people
with healthy guts
who don't have a lot
of health issues,
like a wide variety of plants
and herbs and spices really
seems to induce longevity
and be a healthier
form of a diet,
and that's another thing
we see in a lot of
these blue zones,
they're not highly restricted,
they eat a huge variety,
like a hundred plus
different plants
and herbs and spices,
whereas here in America,
we often...
I think we're somewhere
around like 15 to 20.
- Right.
- And so...
- And so would you say the paleo
and carnivore,
that kind of stuff,
like it's sort of short term
to help fix the gut
inflammation kind of stuff
but not necessarily long-term?
- Yeah, let's say
you have a leaky gut,
you have inflammation issues,
you need to kind of
give your gut a break
or you need to not
have a lot of gluten,
a lot of lectins,
a lot of dairy...
Follow a carnivore diet
or a paleo diet for
like 12 to 16 weeks
to allow your gut to heal
and re-stabilize,
but then begin to
reincorporate things like...
Whatever, kale and
cucumbers and tomatoes
and all those foods
that you might've
been missing out on.
And then probably
the final big thing
that we see in a lot of
these healthy locations
is not the absence
of sugar, right?
We actually see a
lot of these play,
like they like their chocolates,
they like their sweets.
- Mm-hmm.
- They like their candies,
you look at the analysis of...
Centenarians are people...
In many cases,
who have lived 115
plus years old,
I was reading a
fantastic article
the other day about like 20
different 115 year old people,
and a lot of them...
They comment, "Oh, I love to
have my chocolate every day."
"I love my sweets."
And there's even some of them
that would like smoke a
cigarette a day and heal,
but the one thing
that you'll notice
in these folks
and also in a lot of
these longevity hotspots
is almost complete absence of
vegetable oil intake, right?
Canola oil, safflower
oil, sunflower oil,
a lot of these vegetable oils
that we tend to see
especially in processed
and packaged foods
or used in restaurants to cook,
and the reason for that
is because vegetable oils,
based on the fact
that they're comprised of fats,
are what your body
uses to create things
like cell membranes,
cholesterol,
mitochondrial membranes,
your body uses these
oils as building blocks,
and if they are unstable
oils, rancid oils,
oils that have been exposed
to high amounts of
heat or pressure,
what happens is
those vegetable oils
really truly become
a case of you are what you eat,
and they create
rampant inflammation,
weak cell membranes,
poor metabolism,
and so...
Whereas sugar isn't
as big of a deal
as most people think,
vegetable oils...
I tell people,
"You wanna be healthy?"
"Ruthlessly eliminate
vegetable oils from your diet."
And sometimes, that means...
Like me, if I go
to a restaurant,
I literally ask them,
like I'm that asshole
who says like,
"What'd you cook the
Brussels sprouts in?"
Or, "Can I have my salad
but bring the
dressing on the side?"
And then like...
I have like a little
fanny pack I go out with,
and I just have like
a four ounce thing,
got olive oil in there, right?
And I'll put olive
oil on my salad
instead of whatever sauce
or dressing they have
at the restaurant,
'cause I am so aware of
vegetable oil intake,
that's the one thing...
- So you want
everything basically
to be cooked either in olive...
Anything that needs
to be cooked with oil
to be cooked with
either olive oil
or avocado oil?
Does it matter which one?
Heat and all that?
- The top one...
The top ones I like
are butter, ghee,
extra virgin olive oil,
avocado oil, macadamia nut oil,
or any super stable
animal fat like tallow
or suet or any of those fats...
Coconut oil will be another one,
like the fats
that are solid at
room temperature
but not solid at
room temperature,
because like Crisco,
they've been synthesized,
but instead solid because
that's the way
they naturally are.
So yeah...
So when it comes to diet...
Just coming full circle here...
Eat in a de-stressed state,
have some periods of fasting
and protein restriction,
be careful with sugar,
but you don't gotta square
that off completely,
completely eliminate
vegetable oil,
and eat a wide variety of plants
and herbs and spices.
And if you can,
get your genetics tested,
you'll get your blood tested,
just kind of see what
your ancestors ate,
see what your biochemically
kind of like primed
to actually be able
to flourish with,
and that way,
you can take some of those
concepts I just outlined
and then tweak your
diet a little bit
so it's more customized to you.
- How did you get
into all this stuff?
Were you always like this?
- No, no.
I wanted to be a computer
programmer growing up,
I love to like
design video games
and tear apart my hard drive,
and that's really
what I wanted to do.
I also...
Dude, I was homeschooled,
I was president
of the chess club,
I played violin for 13 years,
I wrote fantasy fiction novels,
like I was a total
nerd growing up,
but what got me
into like nutrition,
fitness, physical
culture in general,
was I really fell
in love with tennis
when I was about 14 years old,
and I just started
to look into like
how you could eat healthy to
be a better tennis player,
and I started to run the
hills behind my house,
and my Dad bought me a
couple of 10 pound dumbbells
that I tried to
learn how to use,
and eventually, I just got...
I got so into tennis
and how good fitness
and eating healthy
seemed to make me
that in college,
I studied biochemistry
and biomechanics, physiology,
and wound up just nerding out
on just the entire
science of the human body
and the human brain,
and got a master's
degree in all of that,
and I've just been immersed,
immersed in that
science ever since.
- Where does booze
fit into all of this?
Are you doing any wine?
Are you doing any tequila?
Any anything?
- Well, speaking of blue zones,
most of those folks drink.
- Yeah.
- And for men,
it's about two to
three drinks a day,
for women, about one
to two drinks a day,
but you gotta take into account
the nature of the
alcohol, right?
We're not talking
about margarita mixes
and giant fishbowl martinis,
we're talking about like
organic biodynamic
wine grown in soil
that doesn't have a lot
of water added to it,
though it's less irrigated,
so you got a higher
concentration of antioxidants
'cause the grapes
have been beat up,
and a lower
concentration of sugars
'cause there's less water.
Or you're looking at like...
Fermented compounds like
kombucha, for example,
you're looking at clean,
burning higher alcohol
compounds like vodka
or gin or tequila
often added to bitters
and herbs and spices.
So like for me personally,
I do, at the end of every day,
either a glass of just like
organic biodynamic wine,
and if you don't know,
or you're out at a restaurant,
the three countries
that still do a pretty
good job at that
are France, Italy
and New Zealand.
So like if you're gonna order
a red out of the restaurant,
you're pretty safe with
those three countries.
And then the other thing
that'll do if I'm not
doing a glass of wine
is a very bitterish forward mix,
like I'll pour glass of ice,
a little sparkling water,
put a shot of gin
or vodka or tequila in there,
and then just add
bitters like ginger
or turmeric or lemon or lime.
Or even if I'm out
at a restaurant
and I'm ordering from the bar,
I'll kind of glance
through the cocktail menu
and choose something
that's just like a super
bitterish forward cocktail,
and I'll occasionally...
If I'm having a couple of drinks
'cause it's a long steakhouse
dinner or something,
I'll have my glass
of wine with my meal,
but then leading up to that,
I'll just have the bartender
just over the rocks
give me a selection
of house bitters
with sparkling water
and a squeeze of lemon
'cause those bitters
are actually really good for it,
that's part of why alcohol
can be good for you,
but they also help you to
digest your food better
and they even lower your blood
sugar response to a meal.
So for me,
it's usually like a
real bitterish forward
clean burning cocktail
or a glass of organic
biodynamic wine,
and it turns out
that unless you have
a compromised liver
or you're unable to stop at two
or three drinks,
that alcohol seems
to have a little bit
of a life extending effect,
and it's interesting 'cause
we see that also with the...
Like the plants
and herbs and spices
that I mentioned,
with their built-in
plant defense mechanisms,
or some of these centenarians
who are smoking like
a cigarette a day,
or the exposure to the
radiation from sunlight,
or the stress of heat or cold,
like I was talking about,
it's kind of like this concept
of what's called hormesis,
things that would be bad
for you in large amounts,
like alcohol, which is
technically a toxin,
are actually good for
you in small amounts
because like exercise,
they beat up the body,
but the body in the process
of bouncing back
becomes stronger,
it builds more antioxidants,
the cells become stronger,
and so it's not an idea
of living super clean...
By living super clean,
you can actually become
a little bit more weak,
it's about exposing your body
to these mild stressors...
A perfect example
of that would be...
We know that...
Back to what we were
talking about before
with not going to the gym,
this concept of the
hygiene hypothesis,
kids who grow up on farms
and around animals
and with pets
and who have been
exposed to lots of germs
and bacteria growing up,
they tend to have
stronger immune systems.
Kids who drink raw
unpasteurized milk
with all these microbes
and bacteria in it...
Which would just gross out
or freak out a lot
of parents or people,
like they tend to have
lower incidents of asthma
and allergies because
they're getting exposed
to these microbes,
and so that's another
perfect example of the things
that could crush
you in large amounts
actually help your body
to become stronger
in small amounts.
So alcohol's got a thumbs up
in moderation from
the right sources.
- Right, so from alcohol,
where are you at with
like weed, psychedelics,
that kind of stuff?
I know a lot of fitness people
are sort of big
on weed right now,
even as part of the
workout routine,
or recovery.
- Yeah, I just...
I just interviewed a guy
on my podcast about this,
just a fascinating idea
behind the painkilling
effect of like THC and CBD,
especially for
endurance athletes
like ultra runners
or marathoners,
and also for people who
are in a painful sport,
like fighting or
football or hockey,
it seems like the
use of cannabis
either for recovery
or for pain killing
as an alternative to opioids.
- Mm-hmm.
- Or for being able to
just like get into the zone
and push through
like low-level pain,
like ultra endurance running
for long periods of time,
it's usually
beneficial for that.
Cannabis also, of course,
has a lot of other beneficial
effects for inflammation,
it's wonderful for sleep.
The problem, of course,
is to be careful with the
addictive potential of it,
and also, most of
the research shows
that in folks who are generally
about under the age of 18,
there's a deleterious
impact on mental function,
cognitive function,
brain matter, et cetera,
so be super careful
if you're young.
But there's not a
whole lot of issues
with moderated cannabis use,
kind of like alcohol for adults
and even exercising adults
who need it for kind of
like the pain killing
or the focus effects.
And then as far as the
plant medicine piece,
look, like I think there's a ton
of efficacy to micro-dosing,
like micro-dosing
with psilocybin
or micro-dosing with LSD
or micro-dosing with San Pedro
or Bolga or whatever,
not only for workouts
and exercise,
but for productivity,
for creativity,
for kind of like
merging of the left
and right brain
hemispheric activity
that allows for you to
think in different ways
than you might have otherwise,
and even neurogenesis, right?
The growth of new neurons,
which particularly
happens with psilocybin.
And for some people,
the ego dissolution
or the personal professional
or spiritual breakthroughs
that can occur with larger doses
on an infrequent basis,
like some people will go
to an Ayahuasca journey,
or others will use a
higher dose of psilocybin,
or a whole combination
of different plant
and medicine compounds,
that can also be
pretty transformative,
the problem is a lot
of people will use that
like as an escape to
just kinda check out,
take a whole bunch of psilocybin
and just lose
control of your body
and float off into
bliss for a while
to escape the pain of life
that you should be
confronting head-on
and dealing with in other ways.
Or they're not doing the work,
what's called the
integration work afterwards.
For me, if I do a plant
and medicine journey,
I have like four
or five days scheduled
afterwards for journaling,
for self-reflection,
for deep work
that doesn't involve
the medicine,
but that instead involves me
just like logging my thoughts
and my feelings
and my breakthroughs.
And a lot of people,
and this is the reason why
you'll get folks doing like
their 38th Ayahuasca retreat
and they're still
the same person,
and you talk to them,
they're still searching,
you can see...
Tell they're still
incomplete, et cetera,
it's because they're
not doing the work,
it'd be like...
Taking a pre-workout supplement
and then sitting on
the couch, right?
And not actually going
to the gym, right?
So that's the problem,
is I find a lot of people
will use popping a pill
as an escape without actually
wanting to do the work,
and then, in my opinion,
just turns into
the same situation
as a drug addict
who's just kind of
shooting up to feel good
but never actually benefits
from the intended
purpose of that compound.
So yeah, for the most part,
there's a lot of benefits
to these types of
plant medicines,
it's just that I think
most of the benefits
are achieved by proper use
of them via micro-dosing,
and then...
And I have a whole
section about...
In my book,
about how to properly combine
and stack these different
micro doses for productivity,
for creativity,
for sleep, et cetera.
And then for the
larger journey doses,
I think it should be taken
far more seriously
than people take it,
I mean, the...
Like...
For example, what
I mean by that is,
let's say someone's
going to journey
with plant medicines,
like deep.
- Mm-hmm.
- And actually use
this as a breakthrough,
this would be
something you might do
during a rite of
passage into adulthood,
when you're 15 years old,
with your lover on
your wedding night...
So that you can completely
dissolve all barriers
and just be sitting with them
in full truth serum
for four to six hours,
on your 40th birthday,
and then maybe as you
approach your death in life,
for a near death experience
to be able to release a little
bit of the fear of death,
so maybe somebody might do this
like four to six times
in a lifetime, right?
But a lot of people now,
they're just like,
"Yeah, I'm journeying bro,
I'm on my second trip
to South America this
year for Ayahuasca,"
it's like, no, no, no,
these are pretty serious things,
like you you need to
take them seriously
and acknowledge the
sacredness of these compounds
and also acknowledge the fact
that they're to be used in
very specific scenarios,
in a very ceremonial setting,
and with a great
amount of intention
and work afterwards,
and I just don't
see a lot of people
using them in that way.
- Yeah.
Well, listen man,
I am really gonna
try to incorporate
some of this stuff
for this month
and then beyond,
so I appreciate your time.
For the people
that won't find you
on this little wander
through the woods,
where can we send them?
- Bengreenfieldfitness.com
is a pretty good place,
I just wrote a new cookbook,
that was my latest work,
it's at boundlesscookbook.com,
if people wanna try
out my weird recipes.
I promise there's no
psilocybin on the steak,
but other than that,
it's all in there.
And yeah, yeah,
that's a good place to find me.
- Right on, Ben,
I appreciate it.
- Awesome, thanks, Dave.
- Thanks, man.
If you're looking
for more honest
and thoughtful conversations
about lifestyles,
instead of nonstop yelling,
checkout our lifestyle playlist.
And if you wanna
watch full interviews
on a variety of topics,
check out our full
episode playlist,
they're both right over here.
And to get notified
of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe
and click the notification bell.